alexis poulain bonjour bonjour heureux
de vous retrouver dans la matinale de ft
france alors tir groupé 1 ce week-end
par le gouvernement et ses soutiens sur
la nécessité de la réforme des retraites
emmanuel macron est ce qu'il est en
train de préparer l'opinion
oui clairement alors on a entendu tour à
tour un françois bayrou bruno le maire
edouard fille de mâcon bien sûr lors de
son déplacement et bien d'autres un à
droite comme à gauche au fin ou du moins
dans la majorité présidentielle dire que
la réforme des retraites est inévitable
elle est inéluctable
elle est souhaitable le plus rapidement
possible qu'il va falloir y revenir
ce n'est pas nouveau on entend cette
petite musique revenir depuis que la
campagne de vaccination a pris toute son
ampleur
l'idée est que le monde d'après c'est
celui d'avant il faut accélérer il faut
aller vite et ne le croit dit attention
d'abord le travail
ensuite on verra aussi la santé des
finances publiques et puis on va faire
cette retraite mais elle ne sera pas
forcément la même que celle qui était
déjà dans les tuyaux
l'idée c'est de gagner du temps c'est de
donner des gages bien sûr à droite parce
que aujourd'hui et bien les maquereaux
un bilan difficilement défendable il n'y
a rien finalement c'est ces cinq ans ont
été globalement du vent et beaucoup de
violence sociale
donc il faut aller plus vite et il lui
reste un an pour pour monter le soutien
alors ils préparent l'opinion en réalité
et c'est ce qu'on a vu dans ses
déplacements le premier la semaine
dernière encore un autre cette semaine
avec à chaque fois l'idée de faire
campagne pour 2022 évidemment pour le
régional aussi déguisés sous couvert
d'entendre et d'écouter les français
mais le plan est clair et mener le bac
on va faire un grand discours après le
14 juillet ou au mois de juillet celui
de la refondation pour dire eh bien
voilà donnez moi cinq ans de plus il
faut continuer ce que j'ai commencé
c'est à dire finir ses réformes
structurelles réformes sociales et c'est
ce qu'il dit d'ailleurs danser dans ses
allocutions différentes alors alexis
dernière ligne droite du quinquennat
emmanuel macron entend accélérer
réforme et faire des choses dures qui
pourraient compromettre sa candidature
à quoi est ce qu il fait allusion quand
il dit ça mais à ces choses dures c'est
continuer ses réformes sociales très mal
perçue par la population avec un
président impopulaire à 60% d'opinions
négatives vis-à-vis de son action donc
il sait que de toute façon niveau
popularité il n'y aura pas plus haut
malgré un les dépenses faramineuses dans
les sondages 28 millions dépensés en
2020 dans les sondages et les différents
conseils en communication donc il fait
beaucoup beaucoup de communication
autour de cela pour préparer les mesures
d'austérité à venir en réalité parce que
on attend des rapports pour fin juillet
sur l'état des dettes et des finances de
la france d'être faramineuses du coc
vite bien sûr dette de 20 milliards pour
ce qui est du régime des retraites
la sécurité sociale également endettés
massivement avec la crise du coc vide
mais bien avant des secteurs qui sont
toujours en souffrance que ce soit
l'hôpital l'éducation mais aussi on a vu
plus récemment les syndicats de
policiers manifester et puis c'est une
réforme impopulaire la réforme des
retraites parce que forcément injuste on
veut ne plus parler de pénibilité au
travail
on parle de réformes à point c'est à
dire travailler plus pour gagner moins
on parle aussi de d'allongement de l'âge
de l'espérance de vie en disant qu'il
faut travailler plus
or c'est un mensonge l'espérance de vie
en bonne santé recul elle est de 64 ans
pour les femmes et 63 ans pour les
hommes
et puis il ya une différence d'espérance
de vie énorme entre un travailleur
pauvre et un travailleur aisée c'est 13
ans aujourd'hui selon l'insee donc c'est
énorme et des métiers qui eux n'auront
pas évidemment la retraite à 65 ans
parce que la pénibilité est telle que
c'est impossible donc c'est extrêmement
compliqué on a vu combien c'est
impopulaire mais manuel macron doit
donner des gages à bruxelles qui demande
des réformes structurelles pour avoir
ces aides de relance alors il ne le dit
pas comme ça évidemment mais clairement
l'agenda édictées par la commission
européenne en disant attention si la
france ne fait pas ses références
culturelles elle n'aura pas sans doute
les milliards attendus dz donc mma qu'on
doit aller vite et doit faire cette
politique de communication à tout crin
aidé en cela par par une majorité
disparate
alors les français de les confiner
et en vacances est ce que c'est une
aubaine finalement pour passer des
réformes difficiles
clairement aujourd'hui avec cette
déambulation en france c'est l'un des
éléments de langage de la majorité la
déambulation du président enel mâcon qui
va au contact de français qui sont
soigneusement choisis dans des villages
privatisé pour l'occasion
l'idée est de se mettre en scène et de
dire que je viens de là qu'on est le
grand libérateur qu'il a réussi cette
guerre contre le coc vide que le
confinement cette fois ci se fait en
douceur avec la vaccination bien sûr
mais aussi davantage de contrôles et de
garanties donc il
il donne il se donne cette image du
grand libérateur alors que c'est lui qui
continue à nous mettre un couvre-feu à
21h il faut attendre mercredi pour que
ce soit 23h ces dates n'ont aucun sens
pour une plus salutaire mais c'est pas
grave il faut accepter
donc il joue bien sur cette grande
libération les vacances arrivent en
disant vous aurez le droit prend des
vacances pour les français ils peuvent
bien entendu se payer des vacances
beaucoup ne sont pas dans ce cas là mes
mails macron ne les voit pas dans son
son rapt et maîtres politiques et l'idée
c'est évidemment de passer un maximum de
loi impopulaire pendant les vacances
n'est pas nouveau mais ça risque d'être
assez cataclysmique cet été parce que
encore une fois ces réformes sont
injuste et impopulaire et qu'elles sont
difficiles à défendre mais qu'il en a
besoin parce que si jamais il arrivait
en 2022 sans bilan et c'est le cas
aujourd'hui
ce serait extrêmement délicat le seul
bilan et éventuellement qu'il va pouvoir
mettre en avant c'est ce bilan co vide
mais n'oublions pas c'est plus de cent
mille morts en france c'est un des pays
les plus impactés en europe c'est
beaucoup de mensonges sur les masques et
autres et c'est une répétition en fait
de fiasco qui fait qu' on ne peut pas
non plus se féliciter de la part de
l'exécutif d'une gestion de crises
sanitaires donc voilà un peu quel est
l'agenda du président et il ne pense
évidemment qu à 2022 quoi qu'il en dise
et quoi qu'il va nous en coûter alors un
agenda vous le disiez tout à leur portée
à part bruno le maire le ministre des
finances qui a par ailleurs qui s'est
exprimée qui a annoncé un accord
historique sur la taxation des
multinationales et des gars femmes
écoutez c'est un accord historique
pour la première fois depuis des années
les états membres du g7 sont capables de
définir des règles pour le système
international du 21e siècle c'est un
accord dont la france peut être fière
cela fait quatre ans que nous nous
battons dans toutes les enceintes
européennes internationales
ici au g7 au g20 pour qu'il y ait le
juste taxation des gens du digital et
pour qu'il y ait une taxation minimum à
l'impôt sur les sociétés nous y sommes
après quatre ans de combat la france a
eu gain de cause
il y aura bien une taxation des gens de
digital il y aura bien une taxation
minimale à l'impôt ces sociétés pour
éviter l'évasion et l'optimisation
fiscale qui révolte à juste titre à nos
compatriotes c'est un accord ambitieux
le taux minimal que nous avons fixés
pour l'imposition des sociétés et à 15%
et je dis bien 15 % au minimum c'est un
point de départ et dans les mois qui
viennent nous allons nous battre pour
que ce taux d'imposition minimal à
l'impôt ces sociétés soient le plus
élevés possible alors avec six cet
accord historique selon bruno le maire
c'est une bonne nouvelle
bah oui ça reste une bonne nouvelle
parce que ça va dans le bon sens avec
cette taxation des multinationales qui
passent leur temps en fait à et leur
énergie à échapper à l'impôt
alors certains voient le verre à moitié
plein l'autre le verre à moitié vide
évidemment 15% c'est peu quand on sait
que les pme en france sont taxés à 26 5
% 15 % c'est également une base de
discussion qui a mis des années à
arriver il a fallu une crise thèse comme
le co vite pour que le g7 se mettent
autour d'une table et arrive à ces 15%
mais c'est un peu la montagne qui
accouche d'une souris puisqu'on est à
quasiment le taux d'imposition de
l'irlande qui est un paradis fiscal
intra européen et puis rien n'est fait
pour contrer les paradis fiscaux qui
sont légions de par le monde y compris
en europe et ailleurs
joe biden qui est le sénateur du de la
world all hour qui est quand même le
l'état américain qui organise l'évasion
fiscale en europe on a le luxembourg les
pays-bas la belgique malte le portugal
l'irlande beaucoup plus et n'empêche que
on voit bien que derrière il ya cette
volonté de dire tout le monde participe
un peu à l'effort après après locaux
vides mais néanmoins les outils qui
permettent aux multinationales
d'échappée encore à l'impôt subsiste
existe hélas le g7 ni l'union européenne
ne mette en place les moyens de lutter
efficacement contre les paradis fiscaux
et l'optimisation fiscale qui reste
totalement légale alors avec si ces
dernières heures ce sont aussi les
propos de jean-luc mélenchon qui font
réagir le candidat à l'élection
présidentielle qui sèment le trouble à à
à propos des attentats regardez vous
verrez que dans la dernière semaine de
la campagne présidentielle nous aurons
un grave incident ou un meurtre
cela est hemera en 2012 cela a été
l'attentât la dernière semaine sur les
champs elysées avant on avait eu papy
voise dont plus personne n'a jamais
entendu parler après tout ça c'est écrit
d'avancé
nous aurons le petit personnage sorti du
chapeau nous aurons les événements
gravissimes qui va une fois de plus
permettre de montrer du doigt les
musulmans et d'inventer une guerre
civile
voilà ses bateaux tout ça alors beaucoup
depuis ont dénoncé un dérapage comment
est ce que vous vous observez cette
séquence alexis alors d'abord je crois
que jean luc mélenchon à une formulation
un peu hâtive et malheureuse il voulait
simplement dénoncer le fait qu'il y
avait une instrumentalisation de des
événements sécuritaires à l' approche
des élections majeures et ça c'est un
fait est partagée par beaucoup
ce soit bernard cazeneuve qui en parlait
le figaro d'autres responsables
politiques qui effectivement parle des
défis sécuritaires autre chose
al'approche également de d'élections en
france les organisations terroristes
essaye de déstabiliser le scrutin de
faire un maximum d'opérations ou du
moins d'avoir une épuration qui va tuer
et faire faire parler d'elle donc c'est
malheureux et c'est vrai qu'il ya après
au sein de la presse c'est
sensationnalisme le fait de parler
d'insécurité c'est la fabrique de
l'information qui fait qu'on va
s'attacher à la petite phrase et là jean
luc mélenchon se fait accuser de
complotisme par à peu près tout le monde
il ya une belle unité autour d'eux des
paroles du leader de la france insoumise
et ça montre finalement comment on ça va
s'accrocher à cette parole certes
malheureuse dont certains pensent qu'il
est même une peut-être une stratégie
pour aller draguer sur des terres de
plus des lectorats qui ne me connaît pas
encore ou qui dira ah voilà ils pensent
que moi mais je crois pas que jean luc
mélenchon soit devenu complotistes en
une nuit là il dit simplement trop vite
qu'il y avait effectivement un climat en
france assez délétère et qui risque
d'être encore davantage instrumentalisé
et malheureusement une certaine façon la
façon dont est traitée cette sortie de
jean luc mélenchon temps à lui donner
raison sur le plateau quand il sort
cesser ces termes personne ne réagit et
c'est après bien sûr avec les réseaux
sociaux avec tout le monde qui se met en
marche
on va dire pour pour le dire que c'est
inadmissible et c'est vrai maintenant
tout le monde attend de la part du
leader de la france insoumise des
excuses vis-à-vis des victimes du
terrorisme la merde d'ailleurs d'un d'un
dédain des militaires victimes a dit que
c'était scandaleux ces propos je crois
qu'il a encore quelques jours pour
revenir dessus mais le fond d'une
campagne n'est pas que la forme là on
est vraiment dans la forme et s'attacher
à une petite phrase et ça va faire
beaucoup évidemment de cette campagne de
2022 dont nous allons parler longuement
et ici ailleurs alors vous le rappeliez
un la question de la sécurité au coeur
des débats les préoccupations des
français également avec la justice
montré du doigt notamment par certains
policiers ces derniers jours emmanuel
macron qui a annoncé l'ouverture d'états
généraux de la justice alors encore de
nouveaux états généraux qu'est ce que
vous en pensez mais c'est une technique
devenue caduque enfin on a tellement vu
de grands débats de grandes marges
d'états généraux de convention citoyenne
c'est bon bref un des outils marketing
des monnaies de macron pour finalement
lancer le plus loin possible débat dire
qu'ils écoutent qu'il entend qu'il
organise bien sûr une instance
démocratique de délibération alors qu'il
décide en monarque absolu sur tous les
sujets conseil de défense sécuritaires
sanitaires de 2 to 2 et 2 le fait que le
parlement soit relégué finalement
chambre d'enregistrement
donc là il fait la même chose que ce
qu'il a fait avec le bouvau de la
sécurité il a fait avec les violences
faites aux femmes les chiffres sont
catastrophiques
la réalité va à l'encontre finalement de
cette mise en scène
rituel du pouvoir de cette mise en scène
perpétuelle de campagne puisque c'est un
président en campagne permanente
emmanuel macron et là bas ils utilisent
un outil de campagne pour dire d'un côté
je fais le boulot de la sécurité de
l'autre les états généraux de la justice
donc j'ai entendu tout le monde donc
forcément je vais faire quelque chose ça
ne veut rien dire ça veut simplement
dire qu'ils écoutent qu'il laisse parler
regardez la convention citoyenne est
bien de toutes les mesures qui sont
sortis bien rien du tout finalement n'a
été entérinée et les citoyens qui ont
participé à cette convention était
extrêmement déçus ont eu le sentiment de
se faire manipuler et bien il en est de
même je pense pour tous ces grands
raouts qui permettent de mettre en scène
la l'allèle l'action présidentielle qui
est une inaction totale mais par contre
une communication permanente
merci beaucoup alexis poulin et liteo à
retrouver sur les réseaux sociaux
et puis quant à nous on vous retrouve
lundi prochain dans la matinale de rtl
france